natacha comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voie vous allez avoir droit ça
ne vous étonnera pas à une interview
première fois dans la bouche
alors attention attention premier
souvenir
je sais quand je sautais sur le lit de
ma cousine et je suis tombé je me suis
déchiré le dos sur une étagère de
briques événement c'est bien ma cousine
l'échappée ben ouais ouais la cousine a
eu la chance de ce mal oui premier
chaude j'imagine que c'est celui-là
premier choc
ben non j'ai déjà pris un choc
électrique en voulant jouer à la voiture
que j'avais décliné dans ce qu'elle
avait des clés j'allais rentrer dans la
prise de courant bah ouais voilà c'est
qu'on ne devait quoi 1 3 à 4 ans
je le fais aussi on mange au premier
mensonge off ça doit être une fois que
j'ai dit à ma mère c'est pas moi ouais
c'est son ancien premier péché mon père
mon premier péché oui le mensonge
ah oui on encense quelconque je sais pas
lequel première baffe
j'en ai jamais eu un jamais vous aussi
peut-être même essayé ma fille tu es
mort en des toits oui ben ari ferrari
est un curé tué de curatelle tour eh oui
mon fils je m'en tire bien mais là il
est complètement paumé première idole
céline dion au sérieux sa manie là on
est en réponse mais moi j'aime mon thème
chénard tu aimerais oui oui oui les
derniers seront les premiers
je ne sais plus belles chansons il aime
céline dion elvis presley n'est pas mort
et tonnerre belle robe âgées jamais
porto made à l'eurovision ce dialogue se
mettre à leur dire je vais mettre une
robe donc si elle est belle ce sera la
première premier coup de foudre
premier coup de foudre
je sais pas je vais changer un peu
présent 15 ans 15 ans et alors alors ben
ça a été mon premier mon premier copain
sérieux et alors quoi alors après alors
que je voulais alors après j'ai eu à
notre coup de foudre
ah oui je sors un livre chez latex je
crois qu'on en parle compter sur votre
promo comme s'ils s'étaient pas trompés
y aura deux types de rocard qui avait
très bien marché
premier baiser sur la bouche 14 15 1
première fois avec la langue
je pensais que c'est que je suis là là
là car au québec c'est comme si on met
la langue tout de suite des fois oui des
fois non première fois à 2 j'ai pas
demandé première fois tout seul parce
que bon je peux pas avec le père qui est
là et tout faire il est là t'en va pas
changer ma voix de l'est pas dans les
choix que j'ai couché avec un mec se la
voir je devais avoir la fin de mes 15
ans presque 16 ça vous choque tout ça
très bien première fois à trois pages
que l'on fait mais jamais encore non
c'est pour ça que nous n'aurons pas la
première fois qu à ça je vous le demande
prenez plein d'amour premier chagrin
d'amour il ya
neuf mois à peu près abbas et le vous
avez été donc voilà donc c'était ouais
c'était c'était mon ancien copain c'est
à la première fois on lui pardonne eu à
bah oui on est restés des très bons
codes à barres et reste en commun on
n'aime pas qu'on était des très bons
copains le premier mois après la rupture
mais maintenant oui on a bien première
cuite c'est juste après non présence et
eve première cuite
c'est à chez mes parents je vais avoir
15 ans à 15 ans et elle a raison c'est
vraiment aller demain je baise premier
pétard premier pétard jamais avant il en
existe ou voyez elle est morte en des
noms à la laiterie la lépi
non j'en doute soyons clairs oui je vois
pas en quoi la religion catholique
pourrait nous interdire de plan les des
pétards attendait du match il n'y a pas
de dépendance
oui d'accord mais le bétail pas dès
maintenant pour des fins thérapeutiques
c'est que ça aide beaucoup c'est ça peut
avoir du bon je sais que des gens quand
le cancer et qui ont fait fumer des
pétards
ouais de tous les temps c'est pas la
peine d'attendre d'avoir le cancer je le
dis bon première cigarette or là c'est
beaucoup plus grand mais non plus ça
c'est bien ça je vous félicite
ouais premier valium jamais c'est bien
bravo bravo bravo